les des forums qui ont lieu en russie en
particulier le haut niveau ce coq ce
sont des opportunités pour les grands
groupes
de rencontrer les décideurs on a ce lieu
en un seul en un seul endroit et à une
seule main une seule et même période si
vous prenez en compte la taille de la de
la russie son fractionnement
juste pour mémoire les niveaux stoke 7 à
7 heures de décalage horaire en moscou
c'est vraiment des opportunités en or
puisque vous retrouvez les partenaires
le business les autorités tout ça dans
un même endroit et ce sont des gens qui
viennent justement pour pour un terreau
acté entre entre eux et
les businessmen ce qui permet de faire
avancer des dossiers ce qui permet de
débloquer des situations ou bien de
créer de nouvelles opportunités pour nos
développements
le moyen orient russe c'est comme je
voulais 10 et 7 heures de décalage
horaire moscou mais c'est encore
l'europe aussi prévu que ça puisse
paraître et il faut bien comprendre que
l'extrême orient russe et il est à la
frontière avec la chine avec la corée du
nord à proximité immédiate du japon donc
ce sont des économies extrêmement forte
des populations nombreuses donc il ya
des opportunités aussi les piles ya des
ressources des ressources naturelles
extraordinaires des du minerai du
pétrole du gaz donc vous imaginez bien
que tous ces pays qui sont qui soit en
recherche
d'énergies sont extrêmement intéressé à
développer leurs relations avec la
russie et au delà de saint ylie a eu
jusqu'à 2019 des décors en touristique
extrêmement puissant et qui se
développait
à des pourcentages deux chiffres et
faisait la richesse de ce pays au delà
de ça il y a des
espaces touristiques l'extraordinaire
je rappelle que le tigre de sibérie et
bien il n'habite justement en extrême
orient russe vous avez la presqu'île de
la kamtchatka avec ses volcans c'est ses
geysers et ses paysages absolument
unique donc il y à il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour pour développer cette région
qui qui est vraiment à proximité
immédiate de centaines de millions
d'habitants c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire alors et l'extrême orient
russe est très très pop et l'uimm
les entreprises françaises sont les
premiers employeurs
en termes de sociétés étrangères en
russie il ya des réussites
extraordinaire il ya bien évidemment un
autre risque hitano d'accord qui en
quelques années a su agrandir son réseau
et multiplier à plusieurs fois plusieurs
reprises on est à plus de 60 hôtels sur
sur le pays alors que et on était avec
calcul dit avec quelques unités au début
de l'année 2000 il y à des réussites
fantastique comme les auchan air liquide
total enfin je ne peux pas vous sur vous
il est ce que vous les lister tous mais
encore une fois
le les français sont les premiers
investisseurs étrangers en russie
au-delà du fait qu'ils osent qu'ils sont
les premiers employeurs donc c'est une
riche une réussite extraordinaire et je
pense que les russes sont extrêmement
friands de cette collaboration